the successor Abu Bakr who was also his
father-in-law and whose daughter Aisha
the young child bride of Muhammad one of
his wives that he married he becomes a
successor but only for two years because
he's elderly and he dies so his claim to
fame is what I was saying the rida wars
the apostasy wars so he's the one that
really consolidates Arabia more than
Muhammad Muhammad it begins with and
there's a lot of nominal submission to
him but also a lot of real submission
but once he dies Abu Bakr those two
years he's known as the guy who brings
in and really consolidates Arabia and
then under the second khalif Omar the
first this is when the great Arab
conquests begin So from 636 which is
when Omar becomes the khalif this is
when the jihad erupts on everyone around
Arabia the first part they attack is
what's called greater Syria which really
encompasses the entire you know eastern
Mediterranean Syria all the modern day
countries that you can think of Lebanon
Israel Jordan portions of Iraq people
forget were actually very Christian but
they also attack Persia you know they go
there and even go further so during
Omar's caliphate which I think lasts a
decade that's when you had the massive
Arab conquest so Egypt was conquered
around 640 641 and like I said all the
greater Syria there's pivotal battle,
the battle of the Yarmmuk. I wrote my
master's thesis on that actually over 25
years ago because it's that pivotal.
Historians call it the most
consequential battle in history because
had the Arabs been defeated at the
battle of Yarmmuk, which is a river in
Syria, it's believed that history could
have been completely different. But
because they beat the Romans, that's
when it was like a domino effect and
they conquered, you know, Egypt,
Jerusalem was conquered a year later.
Egypt, like I said, 640, 641, and then
further west until, so by 7-Eleven, all
of North Africa has been conquered and
now they're in Spain. The Arabs
conquering Spain. Now it's important to
keep in mind because most people don't
get this and this is by design I believe
but when we talk about these regions if
I say Egypt or Syria or whatever Morocco
or Moritania to give its historical name
people just had this idea that these
areas were kind of always Muslim or
something those were of course the
heartlands of Christendom not Europe
okay so if you looked at Christianity
the Christian world and it had spread
very far especially after Constantine in
the early 300s because he was the first
Christian emperor but all of North
Africa right so from Egypt to Morocco
all of the Middle East all of Asia Minor
Anatolia what we call Turkey and then
you know Europe of course southwest of
the Danuban Rine. That's Christianity.
That's Christendom. Okay? And in that
one century that we're talking about
from 632 Muhammad's death to 732, which
is the battle of Tours, which is in the
middle or by Poier in the middle of
France, they conquered all that, which
if you look at the map is something like
depending on how you look at it, two or
3/4 6%, let's say, of the original
Christian world and the more important
one because there were five
ecclesiastical centers, you know,
bishops essentially. Rome is the one
that everyone remembers which was in the
west and that didn't get conquered. The
other four did, right? And that would be
Alexandria, Antioch, Jerusalem and
Constantinople itself later got
conquered.
>> Let's say the first 10 years a huge
chunk you Egypt and Syria were taken and
which is by Syria I mean the Middle East
and Egypt and most of what we would call
Libya and then you know Tunisia I mean
think about Augustine St. Augustine
who's known as the father of Western
theology. Well he was from North Africa
from Hippo which I believe is in Tunisia
that too was conquered very early maybe
by like 650s.
>> So continuing my metaphor the Hindus
have taken over most of Europe and half
of the United States and North America.
And what you're saying is that plus the
way the pre-existing population were
being treated by their conquerors is
what gives rise to the crusade.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I mean it depends on the
time we're talking. I still haven't
gotten to what really gave it rise which
is similar. It was more of the same.
Okay. So in other words, what I'm
talking about is you know the seventh,
8th, 9th centuries and that's what's
going on. And you know Europe knows
about it. Europe is also bombarded
especially from Spain because that's not
the latest. They're in the continent
right? They're in Europe. But right
before the first crusade, there was a
new sort of outburst, Islamic outburst.
And now the Turks come onto the scene.
They start coming in really in the 9th
century as slaves, slave soldiers, and
they're very good warriors. So the
caliphates start bringing these Turks
from Central Asia as slaves, and they
Islamize them, and they just train them
to be great warriors, jihadists. And
before long, they essentially take over.
So this is the Abbassad caliphate, the
golden age caliphate. And before long,
you have these Turks, especially with
the Seljic Empire. This is now we're
coming right before the first crusade.
They keep the Abbassad khif as a puppet.
But now they're the real power and
they're the sultan. In fact, the word
sultan means power holder. Okay. The
first crusade is 1095. The Turks really
start spreading and causing havoc around
1037. And it's especially against the
Armenians. You know, you talk about the
Armenian genocide, it actually goes back
a millennium before what we think. It's
not in the year just 1900, early 1900s
or late 1800s. It actually goes back to
the year 1000. And if you read the
sources, and I have in mind, especially
Matthew Vessa, who's a near
contemporary, what the Turks were doing
to the Armenians and of course other
Christians as they went further west
into Asia Minor is just mindboggling. It
talks about tens of thousands of
Armenians is being massacred. Thousands
of churches being set on fire. The
capital at the time ani was known as the
city of a thousand1 churches. All of
which were just completely devastated
and torched. And it's also interesting
to note and a lot of historians don't do
this. They make you think, okay, these
seljixs were nominal Muslims. Yeah,
they're called Muslims, but they were
just fighters who were conquering
whoever. But in the sources, you see the
religious hostility where they like to
go break crosses and decapitate statues
and gouge the eyes of icons and
desecrate the altars. So that also comes
out. And this is now going on until the
year 1071. Now in 1071 you have the
pivotal battle of Manzer which is in
that area. It's actually in Asia Minor
sort of near Lake Vaugh I think again by
the Armenian areas and the Eastern Roman
Emperor the Byzantine emperor marches
one of their largest armies to stop
these Turks and they lose and it's one
of the worst and the emperor gets
captured the first one in like a
thousand years I think. So now after
that they start just spreading further
west and cover all of Asia Minor Turkey
till they're not far from
Constantinople. Now at the same time
these same Turks from the moment the
holy land was conquered it was very
early on a lot of these khifs including
the ambassador who was sort of
diplomatic relations with Charlemagne
pilgrimage was very important to
Christians especially after Constantine
really rebuilt Jerusalem built the
church of the holy supplr where Christ
was buried and crucified and resurrected
was a huge complex so pilgrimages were a
major thing and a lot of Muslims allowed
Christians to come especially during the
Abbassad period you have to pay of
course and put up with all sorts of
things but they would come but now these
Turks they ran havoc they started
attacking pilgrims they started charging
them even more money and then not
letting them go. And one of the worst
anecdotes that was pretty famous that
happened in 1064 was a large German
pilgrimage went to the Holy Land and
among them is described an early source
they describe a very beautiful Abbis had
none who was told don't do it because
everyone knew it was dangerous to go on
pilgrimage but she wouldn't relent and
she went and they say you know all of
them were killed by the Turks and she
was gang raped until she died and then
it says in the end and the Turks did
this very frequently to pilgrims and of
course they were desecrating Christian
holy sites including the holy supplr and
actually before the Turks just so you
don't think it's just the Turks but a
fatimid Khalif from Egypt Hakim Bamah in
the year 109 actually destroyed the holy
supplr raised it to the ground and
according to Muslim sources and I'm
thinking of al- maki who was an Egyptian
historian he wrote that fatim khalif
destroyed 30,000 churches and synagogues
in Egypt and greater Syria which makes
sense because that was a very heavily
Christianized region one of the oldest
and at that time in 109 the pope of the
time wanted to call kind of a proto
crusade they didn't have it at the time
and nothing happened so now it's
building up and you're getting these
Turks doing what they're doing and
they're killing European pilgrims and
now the emperor of Constantinople.
They're right there at his doorstep in
Asia Minor, right across the streets
from Constantinople. So he calls for aid
and that was the origin of the first
crusade.
>> What was the stated objective of the
first crusade?
>> Well, the ultimate goal, of course, was
to have pilgrims to be able to go to the
Holy Land unmolested. That was, you
know, the number one, but it was obvious
that's not going to happen. It hadn't
really happened even before the Turks.
Like I told you, there was a lot of
exploitation and abuse. But now they
were just running, you know, a mock and
killing anyone and everyone abusing
them. So it was basically time to retake
the holy land which used to be Christian
before the Muslims took it because you
couldn't rely on the Muslims anymore. So
it was time to retake and rededicate and
cleanse the Holy Land from these people.
That was number one. But also the second
one which is not really remembered much
or talked about was to help fellow
Christians, the Eastern Church. You know
according to some historians that was
the chief catalyst. And so one of the
verses biblical verses it was basically
you know where Jesus says love God with
all your heart and love your fellow man.
Loving God was going because holy places
mattered then and it was going to
liberate the holy land and loving your
fellow man was helping these eastern
Christians and pilgrims who wanted you
know to go and not be molested. It's
just sad because a lot of people and
historians will argue give you these
cynical motives. This was an old thesis
that I think goes to Steven Runsman
where basically oh a lot of these were
just second sons who just had no
inheritance. So they just wanted to go
and it was it was a colonizing mission
that had no rhyme or reason. Well if you
look at the sources that's all they talk
about is what's happening to Christians
how they're being slaughtered. how the
Holy Land is being defiled and polluted
and how we have to do something about
it. That is unequivocally clear from a
objective reading of the sources. Let's
go back a little to the colonial era
because this is really what you're
describing. Islam stays dominant and
you're right, people forget that Islam,
especially the Ottoman Empire, was the
powerhouse. It's ingrained in people's
mind as if Europe was always super
powerful and everyone else, all these
brown people were just being abused and
scared of Europe. It was the opposite as
we discussed, but especially with the
rise of the Ottomans and these guys last
from 1300s to the 1900s and in 1683
they're in Vienna with two to 300,000
fighters surrounding it. So keep that in
mind. We started off in the 600s with
Muhammad and the first attack on
Christian territory in 636. 1683 now
we're talking a thousand years later
they're around Vienna and they're using
the same logic and rationale and they're
talking about Islam and jihad and you
have three choices etc. And it's not
even just at 1683 to bring it to this
country, the United States. Its very
first war as a nation, meaning after
independence from Britain after that and
now it's its own country, its first war
is with Muslims. The Barbrey Wars and
again they're acting exactly on the same
logic and Thomas Jefferson this great
paragon of enlightened thinking didn't
know Islam as well as he should have
because when he met with what the
Barbrey pirates are doing is actually
attack. So this is very interesting
because it goes back to the idea of
Jiza. A lot of these European powers
instead of fighting with the barbary
Muslim pirates of North Africa whose
entire economy consisted of slave raids
on Europeans as far as Iceland they
would go and enslave them started just
paying them off which the Muslims took
as Jiza tribute. Now when the US broke
away from Britain it was no longer
covered by Britain's Jiza payments and
once the Muslims found that out they
started attacking American vessels in
the Atlantic and in the Mediterranean
and enslaving them and engaging all
sorts of horrific abuses against them. I
talk a lot about that in one of my books
Sword and Scimitar. actually have a
whole chapter about it cuz if you really
read about what was happening to
European slaves, including these
American ones, it was really sick stuff.
So that's what provoked the first war of
America with the Barbrey. But when
Jefferson and John Adams met, they tried
to find a diplomatic solution. So they
met with one of the ambassadors from
Barbrey Abdul something. They say to
him, "Hey, why can't we just have
peaceful trade and work together, etc."
Typical Americans. And he basically he
sounds like an ISIS guy. He goes, "Our
prophet and our holy book says you are
the infidel. You're the enemy and it's
our right to plunder, kill, and enslave
you until you acknowledge Allah alone."
Okay. So my point is just to give you a
sort of totality. We started in the
600s. This is now 1800. First war of
America. Same mentality, same logic.
What's interesting also about the 1800s
is that same year the first Barbary war
is around I think 18 or 1801 it starts.
But in 1798 Napoleon enters Egypt and he
easily conquers Egypt. And this is known
also as kind of the beginning of the
colonial era. So the colonial era you
see Islam go from this super powerful
thing. Now Europe is super powerful
technologically, militarily,
economically, and it starts spreading
out and conquering its former foe.
People don't realize this, but to the
colonial powers, a lot of them saw
themselves as crusaders. They were
continuing the war. I forget his name.
Is it Alan B? But some guy came and when
they entered and conquered Syria, went
up to Saladan's tomb supposedly and
kicked it and said, "We're back."
Meaning, you know, the Franks or the
crusaders are back. So, a lot of these
Europeans, they still understood it that
way. But why it happened? I think
because the Islamic world, its entire
economy was based on war and plunder and
the slave system. Okay, they it never
produced anything the way Europe
eventually went to, especially
technologically and militarily. So I
think once any Muslim region power is
unable to conquer and plunder, it has no
economy and it starts falling apart. So
the Ottoman Empire still persists. And
why does it persist? Because it
westernizes whereas the rest of the
Middle East, Egypt, which was by then
sort of run by the Mlukes and all these
other areas are completely now just
spent. There's nothing to plunder.
There's no economy. Everything's falling
apart. It's very easily taken over. But
the Ottomans, they westernize, which is
ironic because the Ottomans were the
chief standard bearers of jihad. They
actually took to jihad and articulated
more than the Arabs, their forebears
did. That was their thing. Okay? And you
know, underkurk, they actually got rid
of the Arabic script, took the Roman
alphabet, dressed in western attire,
shaved the beards, etc., etc. Everyone
became westward-looking, including, you
know, the Muslims who could because that
was the way to, you know, win. And the
Islamic way, it became a spent force at
this point. And it was kind of an
anacronism. the way he did things was no
longer going to work in this new world
with Europe the way it was.